el enemigo se muestra imbatible
la lucha en argelia es contra unas
llamas que están arrasando bosques en el
norte la mayor parte de esa zona del
país se encuentra en alerta por el calor
este voraz clima sacude parte del magreb
con temperaturas de hasta 50 grados en
la vecina túnez algo nunca antes visto
en italia se registran más de 500
incendios una gran parte de ellos están
en la isla de sicilia y en donde se
reportaron 48 8 grados centígrados el
que sería un nuevo récord de calor para
europa una catástrofe que además está a
la vista de la población local
digamos disfrute este banco ahora viven
pto hemos vivido y aún estamos viviendo
algunos momentos realmente tristes
porque nuestro territorio ha sufrido una
pérdida muy importante y tomará mucho
tiempo antes de que regrese a su gloria
anterior al esplendor de la bolsa en
grecia la destrucción sobre la isla de
eubea la segunda más grande del país es
evidente incluso desde el espacio son
más de cien mil las hectáreas consumidas
por el fuego en toda la nación de la
mano de la lluvia los bomberos están
consiguiendo controlar las llamas que
ande el norte del territorio llamado
crisis y la crisis climática hasta aquí
nos demuestra que todo debe cambiar
ahora desde la orientación de la
economía a nuestra política de energía
nacional desde el funcionamiento del
estado a los hábitos diarios de la
ciudadanía que tienen que ver con el
medio ambiente que a putin y turingia tu
cara tus
esta ola de calor que trae un aire
cálido de áfrica podría aún tener un
máximo de temperaturas este fin de
semana en varias naciones del viejo
continente mientras que aquí nba ya son
más de 50 mil las hectáreas consumidas y
con una amenaza también para la fauna